on this week's show should I go into
debt to invest in property in the news
we take a look at the world's worst air
B&B and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I also leads I'm Alistair Cunningham and
welcome to the property investors
podcast we've got a great week even
talking about dare to average and you're
gonna be showing us the world's worst
Airbnb I'm looking forward and it's
gonna be a really good show before we
get started if you had a good week yes
you know I've just been in twin events
lots of back-to-back training with crash
course DfE I mean we had a few days off
at weekends Alastair put the company
cars behind behind the bar and invited a
few friends out the layer that the crash
course how much how much was the power
of the barbell fracture more than that I
had permission
stuff just a fraction more it's a
fraction more at six grand so he had a
really good night Eric right now I was
in bed I heard it was a storm
I actually a very chilled out I mean
obviously we did they deal fine
extravaganza which was really good yeah
nice venues at a new venue we've never
been there before and I'm it was very
nice very nice and then I have a chilled
weekend what you up to
I went to literally went I live in
Litchfield went down to the park walk
down had lunch came back there's a canal
was too late food is that right don't
think so there's water there's water
yeah so it's not canal is a river it's
like it's like a lake did you know what
though I used to think it was a canal
yeah until I went to walk alongside the
canal yeah I realized he was actually
just a very long thin like okay I don't
know but when I've been out with Samuel
there you walk over Brittany see I
thought that was a bridge right and
because the lake comes up to the bridge
but if you look the other side there's
no there's no whatever sighs yeah okay
yeah that's funny yeah there's a bridge
that is really quite nice what I like
about that area there is there's so many
nice food restaurants so like I've a
trauma go you go to a different
restaurant
yeah mama tai it's the bank where were
we the other day we were out somewhere
over there on Friday
remember and we were like we walked
reiji's trying to find someone decent to
eat in which could all my days yeah I
had a good wake oh that wasn't a good
day we ended up in Newcastle upon
underline yeah but anyway what I've hole
is even just get coffee we really
struggle didn't ended up with so capo
Nero
when even that was horrible at East
grotty yeah anyway so a lot of people
come to us and they sort of say oh I'm
in debt what should i do should I get
myself a debt first
what's the difference between good and
bad what you know when is it leverage
it's kind of all a bit messy cuz they're
about you but growing up for me it was
like debt was always a bad thing yeah it
was you avoid debt at all costs you know
so like even even things like credit
cards and that I never did any of that I
was brought up you don't go into debt
and debt is a bad thing the only thing
you can notice that is a mortgage
mortgage am outside of that you buy your
college to buy my cars outright it was
everything was what I always I'd always
save up it was the save up pay for it
that was how I was brought up I don't
know about you yeah whereas now I can
see that you know what we teach is the
clear difference between good and bad
debt so what's good debt to you good
there's in for anything you buy using
somebody else's money that will bring
you income or that were accruing
crew has an asset so an asset basically
Robert Kiyosaki talks about good day bad
day bad day prime example is like
finance on cars finance on holidays
clause anything that's going to cost you
money and not actually appreciate in
value or bring your own income every
month so like bad debts would be that
whole these Clause cars general spending
putting things on credit card for no
reason whereas good day it would be
purchasing a house purchase an asset its
purchasing rights to a business or
something
it's going to bring you either an income
or a dividend or a capital appreciation
of some description yeah I'm all but
over a period of time I was speaking to
a friend of mine the other day he just
bought a new house and I went round he
was showing me he wanted to show me
through the plans that he'd got because
he's planning on totally changing it
it's like the three bit house he's
turning it to a four-bed house and
downstairs it's quite a strange layout
because it used to be a shop it's all
very roomy he's gonna make it all open
plan him just show me the stuff and I
was I was like well it's gonna look
amazing when you win you when you
complete this is quite a nice house
quite a nice area and he was like yeah I
said I said how much value do you think
it's gonna it's gonna add to the house
and anyway he goes through some of the
figures and I said to me you know the
amount how much you spend on it and ends
up I mean he's not doing it for this
reason but it ends up actually being a
really smart thing to do it's gonna add
a lot of value to the house yeah some
costing about 60 grand okay but it's
gonna add on about 100 nods Graham's
worse with the houses investment it is a
good investment yeah however that there
was many many people out there that they
still believe to this day that their
home their livings an asset and they
believe that's good debt yeah but it's
not really isn't is it it's not about
it's not I wouldn't say it's the worst
but Robert Kiyosaki says it's still an i
it's not an asset it is a liability
because it takes money out your pocket
every month it doesn't put money in your
pocket it just both it doesn't it is
going up in value as well what if he's
not gone up in value what if you live in
the north where it's not going up in
value it's not gonna value for you but
you are but you are you everybody will
go up in value eventually you are buying
it okay so it becomes becomes an asset
when it's gone up in value at the minute
it's a liability yeah because it's
costing money it's costing mortgage is
costing insurance maintenance hey I mean
I'm all for renting where you live
ya know you're I'm up so I'm not gonna
argue with you but I do think I think
it's a bit of a gray one man yeah anyway
you know he's gonna make a fair bit when
I said to him what are you gonna
remortgage it he said no I said why and
he said basically he doesn't like the
interest payments okay you'd rather just
have much less and pay pay off the house
as fast as possible right okay three
mortgages that he doesn't have to pay
more interest and whatnot
as I hammer how much interest you paying
2% so if you could pull out like a
hundred thousand pounds yeah you could
invest that easily even if you did it
badly can make ten percent return on
your investment and then you be making
an extra eight percent so even your
money it's like one of the cheapest
loans you can get but yeah yeah we just
don't like it no she's very enough but
to me that is like really good debt yeah
very mortgaging the house and you
investing it against Marley you're going
into a very small interest but some
people just in their head just debt no
it's pay off debt pay off debt and
that's like I said how I was
broadcasting isn't it sir it's an old
generation like my parents like that my
grandparents are like that it's an all
generations but I find a lot of the sort
of younger generation are more they're
happy to get into debt but there's been
the rights or not they were happy get
into there yeah and there's more debt
now than there ever has been in history
and it's because people are very easily
they're very happy and very easily
getting to date for for whatever they
want but the problem that you've
probably got is a lot of people are
doing it for the wrong sort of debt so
they're they're getting in today to keep
up with the Joneses and to to live that
lad sort of them so would you buy there
will new ways Essex lifestyle and things
you buy furniture on Finance for my
rental property for your own property no
why because I just wouldn't why this
could occur seven wise and right you to
answer one of the why I thought I don't
know why the minute I just wouldn't
because to me it's it's not actually
making it's not is it's just not it's
not our it was interest rate Oh if his
interest free or very low interest 1% if
it was interest free then yes 1% 2%
interest potentially why because if it's
very low interest or interest free and
as long as I can afford to pay it that's
fine I feel there's a bit of a balk
coming no but um see I wouldn't might
but I don't know why I wouldn't I
suppose depending on what I was gonna
use because even now it's it feels like
it fit our nature it just doesn't seem
right to me but it was not percent then
you
if for instance there's a software you
buy an op set interest for a year then
you'd be Daffy not to as long as you're
gonna fight as long as it wasn't gonna
do as long as you know you could you
know argue that like let's let's say
you're two grand you can spend on the
sofa yeah or on a suite and you're gonna
get it on interest for maybe monthly you
could then use that two grand to invest
into it they gave you more money back so
you can't say with the smart thing to do
we've already got the low interest there
or interest free a lot of them have a
lot of them are interest free for
certain amout of time aren't they they
sting you at the end so I suppose in
that case you use the interest free if
you know that you can afford to pay it
off over the six months yeah it's all
about budgeting and then what you can
and can't afford the danger of going
into debt and doing things that I can
use that money for this and use that
money from this is you can over leverage
yeah and if you over leverage it and
then and then something goes wrong with
this and you need to pay that off a new
car so then that interest comes up and
then you've got a drag money over here
and you get into that spot debt spy you
know what I've seen happen many times
just from like with people unknown who's
at is they get like I saw foreign
finance hundred-pound and they get a TV
on Finance for a phone and they had the
they have all this sort of stuff on not
percent or a very low interest because
they think well I can keep the money
that was gonna spend to keep it in a
bank but then they spend that money in
the bank on just living and you know and
just living up yeah but they've still
got all this debt over here are this
good not getting paid every month and
it's like what you see it's a vicious
circle it comes to mind off you've got
to be very very sensible you've got to
be very very sensible and if you're
gonna get in today for for to build
assets that's brilliant but you still
even then you've still got be very
sensible early
day it should be taken incredibly
serious don't don't think of it as well
just get some day to buy an asset now
it's got to be a good asset it's got to
be the right sort of day yeah I totally
agree I think it can it's a very
powerful tool yeah
and we're very lucky that we live in a
society where we can use that tool it's
a variable for leverage because you can
you you know if you can borrow money to
invest and make more money it's like
you're making free money yeah so agree
Liam you know you can use it very
sensible what do you think what do you
think about not percent interest credit
cards and things like that
well what ie are used to use that when I
was when I first got my back when I was
that when I was about
20 my car insurance is very high okay
and it was kind of a case of you can I
ever paid off all in front yes like
ground yeah
or you can pay like I don't know what it
wasn't move maybe a 120 pound Inman for
what everything worked out about 500
more expense yeah so what I used to do
is I used to get on an interest-free
credit card and just pay the credit card
off mom say mmhmm
instead of the car insurance just been
wise it's my hundred quid and they even
make moving moving credit cards that
have their to not presents it's just
being savvy with your money and I think
you can move that onto another one you
can consolidate the debts onto one
credit card pay this is the key though
you pay it off pay it off you're here
that's the what people do is they just
get more debt and more debt and more
debt and more debt more debt and the
biggest tip I've seen this happen many
times as well it's people move our
balance from one credit card to a 0% and
then suddenly they've got a credit card
with zero balance but 2,000 per credit
limit and then suddenly they say they're
not going to spend it they're not going
to use it but like two months time
they've got two grand on there so then
you've got two credit cards with 2/3 on
each and it's just cycle without being
discipline isn't it they are very
disciplined discipline is key
understanding never go into debt if
you're not going to invest that money
you can if you're gonna invest the money
so like for example buying a house and
you being an idiot or not going to down
buy a house so ya know just to buy out
the cash out right well you wouldn't do
that because why would you buy one house
when you could use the cash and buy four
houses leverage isn't it leverage and
you can and and you can you can be
creative you know I do very strongly
believe in good debt if it's an
investment
mm-hmm I think that's the rule of thumb
really if it's an investment like I said
earlier a good day if it's an investment
if you're if you're using that money to
get greater returns someone you're
putting in that it then it's good as
leverage as long as you're disciplined
yeah as long as it's manageable and
you're not overstretching yourself so if
something goes wrong it's one of the
things that we talked about with the BA
refurbish we find out strategy yeah is
people borrow the money to put in and
then when the when they wondering where
goes to refinance it MMH
cause the value where so it's worth less
than it is then then scuppers you know
screw didn't know it's Danny is a
dangerous game and when you're playing
with yeah you just gotta be careful I
think you've got me super super careful
it's a business decision entity and
you've got to look at it from all angles
not just our oh yeah I can get I can get
a couple of 10 grand on or not as alone
and just wasted you've got invested say
anything invest it wisely you got to yes
have you got any stories where you use
good debt yeah I used okay so the most
recent case of me using day it was what
I have I joined the Academy that was
there that was that was very credit card
gone so III paid like a 2,000 pound
deposit I'm just some debit card and
then I I spoke to enlisted see this is a
responsible of Barclaycard I would say
and so my credit limit on my battle cry
was four and a half thousand pound I'm
obviously you know the Academy you know
how much it is and that's not going to
cut it so I needed to raise about ten
thousand pound I didn't have ten
thousand burn out about a couple grand
in my bank maybe 4 grand 4 grand paid to
talk a couple I'm left and I literally
made a 20-minute phone call to
Barclaycard
and asked them just to increase my
credit limit and I got the basically
said to me look we'll take sure you new
credit limit in the next 24 hours and
about literally half an hour later I got
a text from Barclaycard
saying my new credit limit is now
sixteen thousand eight hundred pound so
they put my credit limit up from four
and a thousand to sixteen and a half
thousand five in this space of a
20-minute phone call now yes I've got
very I had I've got very good credit
I've got no nori years I've never had a
rears what so I'm a good client I'm a
good customer to them and but still
hello responsibles that and why wait a
minute
in twenty minutes
I don't know but I just thought it was I
just remember thinking that's a little
bit too quick because but why because
they didn't even ask me what I wanted it
for not really and I didn't yeah I never
discussed what I wanted it for so I just
think it's a little bit too easily too
easily available you might if you were
irresponsible right and you a lot then
being which well no no I if you were
responsible and you waste and impair
them back the next time that go on your
bike mate yeah but you could perhaps see
about just got a chance as long as you
do a good credit are you paying off the
trustee but in today
that's why I paid for the Academy and
then I paid that card off within like
seven or eight weeks and I just dropped
the credit went back down to four grand
so I I never understand people to do
that well becau I just did because I
believe I have a bigger credit rating
yeah because that if I need it now if
you need it again now make phone call or
20 minutes yeah but they might say
that's a good point actually it's very
good why would you drop it down you just
taking the light do you not trust
yourself well ya know cuz I've got four
credit cards and all of them got zero
balance yeah so like I'd wanna I'd
rather it mine was a million it's a good
point actually I didn't even I didn't
really think about just thoughts the
natural it's the thing oh don't want
that cut that damn but strictly strictly
straight I didn't even think about that
and so you just mentioned that I should
have just left it where it is because I
didn't need the money I don't need the
money now but it would be handy wouldn't
it if you need something come about and
you wanted it you would stay oh yeah
yeah I said Tristan yeah I might have to
have a phone call with them we don't
need it I don't need it I just want it
it's water
okay let's try going to Vegas yeah it's
got the bar actually you could probably
afford it on that credit card anyway
it's that time for this
[Music]
I guess on the news this week we had to
take a look at the world's worst B&B
right let me just explain a very quick
story so hot Bertha I think he deserved
it just for bigot on a Hotspur found to
be honest but whatever his shots
discover his 100 pound the night room in
Amsterdam was actually just a shipping
container of a portable toilet so
basically taught him a plane IAC's
massive game and he booked on Airbnb he
goes along he's driving in the taxi up
and down the road he's like where the
hell's my my cottage on the on the side
of the roads this shipping container
which has got three matches three of his
mates all staying in this cottage just
three matches on the floor and a
portable toilet to the to the side of
that that was it is it doesn't even look
nice inside or is it looking good
pictures up on the screen actually
looked but the mattresses were just
thrown on the floor when there looks ok
actually but it is just a shipping
container now the problem with it is he
then of he then thought stuff this yeah
and went to stay in a hotel
yeah ask the guy for a refund the guy
said no because it was there yeah he put
our complaint into air B&B air B&B
refunding the money themselves to go
there will look bad but then the council
because literally what they done is they
just dumped this super container on the
pavement on the side of a road it wasn't
like land they owned or anything so that
was that that was the big problem and
they then they towed it away so for me
there's two issues with it issue number
one is that is that it wasn't their land
so obviously number two is they referred
to it in the ad as a cottage right so
cottage it was clearly a cottage now I
mean what you rent out as a cottage yeah
this was just a shipping container
having said that I think if they let's
say you had some land that you owned and
you've got plan commission to put some
shipping containers up and you advertise
it as a shipping and
I know it could be quite retro can do
not think people would love that if it
was if they were done up nice I think so
people are camping don't know people
happy to stay in a tent you have been
camping ever been camping yeah yeah i've
been loads and do you like it no no but
was about twelve I don't know what's
worse walking up to a campsite where
tent or rock not to the side of the road
into shipping the word camping
experience Horton there as well the
worst camping experience as well yeah
but if that's summer metal container
it's gonna be kind of in three blocks
and a freakin metal box come on man
we're portaloo the worst County
experience I ever had went to this
campsite and it was on like a slight
hill and we were like we're not bad
things what actually happened was they
season the night in the night we just
sort of like fell to the bottom at the
bottom of the tent and then it rained
and leaked so it's like lying and like
why would anybody go canvass not
enjoyable is it it's not a holiday is it
the only reason I would go camping but
you know what kids we're about to go
camping oh yeah
no you are oh yes we are going camping
not a tent we like we're leaving if you
guys are watching this satellite on
Saturday we're leaving tonight we're on
the plane pretty much this sort of time
here we end going now we're not going to
camp me I've seen this we're paying good
money it's not camping it's like it's
this thick it's a building it's got its
it really is oh right so my bottom line
is is that I actually think it's totally
acceptable we're not when I get up and
talk about service accommodation I say
there's no legislation that you know you
could literally
as long as you're clear we're honest
about it so why did the air B&B ban off
white because they banned off the site
why was that it's illegal because it's
misdescribed it's miss sold illegally
put on the side of a road oh yeah okay
but it's miss described it was described
as a cottage yeah it's not so shipping
could shipping container yeah so if he
described it as a shipping container cuz
they B&B them could yearly he doesn't
own the line I just call it like a retro
although apparently I was I was reading
on the article apparently someone did
put it igloo up in their garden yeah
well air B&B don't care that you don't
own the land cuz it'll ask them
questions do they they don't care but
all they care about is that it's
described probably so if he described it
as are this is their reason
misrepresented or forgit listings have
no place on our platform so yeah so he's
represented it as a cottage it's not a
cottage so if he just said a metal box
so if you had a picture of it like that
yeah doesn't look like a cottage that's
it a caravan there's like a static home
yeah if you just put mobile home I don't
know do you know what it looks like you
know I'm building sites you know when
you see like the builders they normally
put a couple of containers on site and
therefore like builders to have the
lunch and in the same as well very
serious it's one of them that they've
just painted that's always I used to do
a bit of work with the BBC where on some
of their shoots like a consultant and
and look he sounds really glamorous but
it really isn't yeah and a lot of it is
like that wait where you go and have
lunch and where the changing rooms and
stuff it's all like it looks just like a
shipping container
yeah he's too bad I think you know I'm
sure there'll be someone out there that
can you know buy a bit did you imagine
the company garden because you imagine
when you rock up the Amsterdam you think
you can have a bang and weekend because
it's the taxi drivers going up and down
the show anyway I can't fade the court
[Laughter]
is very funny check out the ask you
haven't seen I'm sure limit is very
funny
right it's now time for this
[Music]
okay it's now time for your questions
and our answers before we go into that
if you want to ask this question in the
future probably one the best places to
do it is obviously on YouTube don't
forget to subscribe to us on YouTube as
well
or you can go on the Facebook group we
know we do a Facebook live at some point
during the week the Facebook group is
property investors with Samuel Leeds
join that group and then you can ask us
questions on there as well which will
then answer on the show also if you do
as a favor if you're listening to this
on Apple podcasts please do leave us a
review as long as it's a good review
don't leave us a bad of it you can leave
battery balusters but if it's about me
please be please be good I don't mind
bad reviews that he's used to it now
he's reading a book what's taking all
the bad reviews or my comment your
comment so first question here you go
this was from Harry Jackson this was
from on the Facebook group and his
question is this Alastair Cunningham yes
what is the best way you find B and V
deals this is a topic we've actually
discussed quite in depth assignment on
quite a few videos about it I'm sure
Nick can have a link to some things that
alright Nick some of the videos Sam has
done and but some of the ways I do it I
look for a properties that are a little
bit rundown so our tip is look at
carpets if they are like was your
personal house BMV no not really so if
the carpets are bit old and dated look
for old furniture look for decoration
it's a bit poor and rundown I'm not
saying that your house is rundown but
your personal house I'm not trying to
suggest that it's old fuddy and rundown
no it's not I'm just just clarifying
that he lives in a nice house
thank you right okay so actually a very
very nice house thank you
okay so too nice for anything anyway
look at carpets look at decoration and
look for this old on your big tip before
you reinvest listen to look at carpet
yes okay
carpet right got crap loads of them no
all dirty carpets discolored wallpapers
because if like lots of signs of aging
Rondon property now the reason I say go
for random probably is an age in
discoloration what sort of stuff is
because they're the ones you're gonna be
able to get a bargain on now BMV is blue
mark blue market value now you're not
gonna see a property listed as are this
is BMV if you do it's very rare you have
to negotiate a BMV and the way i do that
is by picking all these highl all these
points and sort of emphasizing how much
they're gonna cost him to put right and
then negotiate a blow a market value
deal I remember the last time we talked
about being V we had a big argument
about what being because you said
there's been V and then there's blo
market value and it's below true and I
said no there isn't
the asking price and low market value
yeah and we argued about it for a while
cuz I kind of agree we you know do you
can yes we can move on from that right
okay so maybe maybe we can bypass that
BMV listen you're only gonna get that if
you learn ago she ate you got be a
killer negotiator and you're not going
to negotiate on a property that's
immaculate you need to negotiate and
property that's a little bit rundown and
tired and there's Lords out there so one
is less people because most people
because they're mine for themselves yep
don't want a house that looks horrible
so the house looks horrible during me
less buyers therefore the seller has got
less choice and then you can oh you
could you can knock them down 100% so an
example of one I've just secured
recently and I'm buying myself is a
property's worth one hundred and five
thousand we've got a cynic two grand and
the reason we're going to grant is
because it is it needs a full reefer but
the refurb the the vendors who's got it
they've been caught like thirty five
thirty five to forty thousand pounds to
do the reverb on it I know I can get the
reef up done for twelve to fifteen I'm
not gonna tell them that I let them
still think it's thirty five to forty
thousand pounds so when I went in to him
I wrote my price of like low seventies
today I'm that still fair because
seventy plus Tara is what is really
worth I can get the reef up done for ten
twelve thousand buy moon fifteen max I
found a brilliant yet BMV property in
Amsterdam was this little cottage cool
side of the road
serious discount in the proces being
towed away so you act fast fast all
right next question I did see one on
YouTube okay so this is a question from
Alex Snelson and it's on YouTube Alex
Nelson it's Nelson yes is there a
minimum age to allow you to release
equity or refinance your current home
after adding value do you mean an age as
in for the yourself I'm assuming if
you've already got a mortgage then
you'll be fine so basically it's
mortgages isn't mortgage age age
mortgage age so like 18 or 21 to 18 for
our future parents no but 21 is you as a
buyer to like wait is this for a
remortgage yeah well no no it doesn't
say remortgage and says refinance your
current home after adding value if your
assignment you're refinancing it means
you've already got financed refinance
yeah you can get financed it's just your
mortgage age so as long as you're over
the age for mortgage I would pick the
broker and be very very good and right
okay so another question from Dale
Lancaster last one was this YouTube this
is on YouTube hi my name is Dale Lydell
love the podcasting Dale it really does
mean a lot gets us right yes yeah right
my question is with a property that has
shared ownership how would you go about
getting the best possible deal or is
there not one and they're like Hugh
answer that questions I don't like
shared ownership and I know you don't
know much about it so I'm gonna like you
answer the question so if he's got
probably Scott shared on a ship right
how would you go about getting the piss
no so what does I mean he wants to get
the best possible deal on a shared
ownership property so do you know one
right move you see properties are
available for shared ownership he wants
to get the best deal on that yeah really
to be honest we don't both of us don't
agree with shared ownership because it's
it's a government scheme that will
probably be out to benefit the
government and not you so I don't agree
with it I don't like it and I don't
advise it and what do you think I've
never bought a shared ownership
I wouldn't so I wouldn't do Sark I don't
feel qualified to comment on it but
thanks for you thanks for your quick
your best dealers don't I personally
only got 40 grand just go and buy a
house up north yeah I will actually rent
where you live and then use that money
if you've got 40 grand to invest or 20
grand whatever I would just rent where
you live where it's good up north we can
buy a house for 40 grand whole whole
right one more question or did you say
that was last week I did one more it was
20 years we got to him for 20 years
right okay ah this is from Richard Baron
hey Richard it's on YouTube again
originally not a question it's a
statement like oh well that's a nice way
to end we're gonna head this is how
honors we are that you've commented
Richard we are ending the show I don't
know what it is but I don't confident
like it it better not be praising you or
not may is Richard Ferreira to remember
that Richard Baron owl is looking slim
and trim and on that bombshell thank you
very much have an awesome week guys we
will see next week do not forget to
subscribe we're back Saturday at 7 p.m.
see that see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]